for Kerry Tate the family business means
everything we're prepared to make an
offer today that's a ridiculous offer
Emerson Foods is a family company very
big family company so when her sister
has some joyous news Mary I would like
to introduce you to my best friend and
my best man we've met we get it no
carries about to get humbugged my mother
she had it in her will that whichever
one of you marries first the company
would immediately go to that daughter's
husband legally Ethan will own Emerson
Foods now technically I could still get
married first
Zelda I have a plan Carrie's about to
learn that love and happiness always
find a way and the fact that you two
love each that is so completely that's
amazing
makes me happy to think that it exists
and maybe one day from lucky enough a
little bit of that will rub off on me
Mar Vista Entertainment presents just
McAllen Kobe Bryant McLaughlin April
ball V James Eckhouse and League
Arlington in a romantic holiday comedy
about finding that love is more
important than any family business right
Christmas
married by Christmas
you